[Music]
you say ripoff I say inspired by
hello Internet welcome to film theory
forever changing the way you look at all
your favorite franchises and today I
have a particularly juicy little
conspiracy for you on one of the most
important beloved franchises in sci-fi
velaryon oh and also Star Wars maybe
you've heard of that one maybe you've
heard of them both so I was fortunate
enough to see a preview of the new movie
valerian and the city of a thousand
planets in part because they value high
quality YouTube content but also in part
because they hashed agz sponsored this
episode thanks guys Roddy and extra
bread loaf tonight and if you're like me
prior to researching this episode then
you probably don't know too much about
valerian other than it's a new movie
coming out starring The Enchantress from
Suicide Squad only this time with fewer
hula hoop hips and two times the bikini
yes I counted while I was watching the
movie but here's a mind blow for you you
probably know more about valerian than
you think as it turns out valerian is
actually an inspiration for almost every
other space based alien battling
captain's logging series you've ever
seen and maybe even something a little
bit more for your favorite galaxy far
far away Star Wars now I can already
hear you calling blasphemy trying to
force choke me through your computer
monitors but set your phasers to stun
because you're never gonna look at
George Lucas's space epic the same way
again after I show you how your favorite
moments from Star Wars they have just
begun as your favorite moment from
valerian before I start preaching the
galactic truth here's a little history
lesson for you
valerian started as valerian and Laura
lein a French comic series from the year
1967 valerian and Laura lein follows a
time-traveling galaxy hopping agent who
spews sarcastic remarks named fittingly
enough valerian and his partner the
equally kick-butt Laura lein did he kind
of call them a regular han and Leia they
hop between planets investigate alien
species and tackle all kinds of personal
and intergalactic issues along the way
sound familiar
well the only one to really beat them to
the punch in this fictional space race
was the original Star Trek which
technically premiered one year earlier
but the worlds and adventures created by
balerion were entirely unique at the
time the series was a pioneer in space
fiction one small step for man one giant
leap for fan kind okay this is all well
and good but that isn't why you clicked
this video what would prompt me to make
the extreme claim that Star Wars may
have borrowed an idea or two from
valerian well you don't have to listen
to me let me lay out the evidence so
that you can judge for yourselves let's
start where Lucas's Space Odyssey starts
Luke Skywalker's home planet of Tatooine
it's a desert wasteland populated by a
ragtag alien population of traitors and
has the particular quirk of having two
sons and remember Tatooine originated in
Star Wars Episode four in the year 1977
may I now present to you the planet CRT
from Valerians empire of a thousand
planets desert wasteland setting check
lots of types of aliens who are on the
planet to trade with each other check
two suns bolt shown and referred to as
sons check and check and CRT made its
first appearance back in 1971 six years
earlier than a new hope but okay
obviously that's one small series of
details that's a long way from ik
waiting the whole of Star Wars to the
whole of valerian but hold on all your
nerf herders I'm just getting warmed up
next up on the chopping block is return
to the Jedi from 1983 which came out 16
years after valerian and Laura lein
started remember this scene
don't deny it you washed it like 80
times between the ages of 12 and 15
obviously to figure out why Luke doesn't
walk into the scene with a lightsaber I
don't know why else you would be
watching it over and over again during
your developmental years but if you can
manage to pull your eyes away from
Luke's lackluster rescue plan what you
may have missed was this princess Leia's
new duds a metal bikini known as the
Slave Leia outfits see it pays to
observe all corners of the frame this
costume design and Return of the Jedi
seems pretty memorable right a brown and
gold metal bikini it's pretty unique
like if you've seen it before you'd
remember having seen it even if it had
been a few years earlier say 11 years
earlier in 1972 in a graphic novel stand
by you guessed it valerian in Valerians
land without stars Laura lein has taken
prisoner on a slaver ship by the evil
Burrell's APAR who no joke has designed
his empire so that women do all the work
while he relaxes at his palace of
resplendent virility compensating there
much there buddy so Laura lein is in
this slave ship as a part of the harem
but not just that she's wearing an
outfit that may remind you of something
which just begs the question who wore it
better outfit materials it's made out of
setting it's funny isn't it how
interstellar female slave outfits share
such common characteristics with each
other despite being in such vastly
different parts of the galaxy and again
in the interest of showing you the
evidence and letting you be the judge
here's Jabba the Hutt and here's emperor
el Zafar is it a coincidence that both
rulers could stand for a solid juice
cleanse and remember the valerian
designs are coming a decade prior but
okay all that is still pretty minor
stuff design aesthetics setting details
but here's one that might raise an
eyebrow for you one of the signature
scenes of Empire Strikes Back is
witnessing Han Solo getting frozen in
carbonite to see one of the movie's most
beloved heroes wind up incapacitated
like that is shocking
almost as shocking as saying lay in the
bikini no judgement anyway the whole
thing feels very reminiscent of a moment
in Valerians empire of a thousand
planets where valerian has taken
prisoner by a race known as the
enlightened to be interrogated about
earth's secrets to do this
they encase him completely in a hardrock
substance that looks and sounds an awful
lot like the Carbonite in Star Wars
even showing him in an unfortunately
familiar position where he has to be
rescued later by Laura lein observe if
you will the color of the rock the
thickness of the slab the overall
dimensions of the casing its see any
parallels again I'm not here to judge
I'm just a messenger of information the
other detail here worth mentioning is
that valerian experiences memory loss
after he comes out of his carbonite
she'll hit his rocky shell seeming to
have what Star Wars later refers to as
carbonite sickness han Solo experiences
this as temporary blindness but one of
the other Kanin symptoms of Carbonite
sickness is you get
memory loss okay but Star Wars is filled
with so many other designs and moments
even if a few elements were maybe
inspired by valerian there are dozens of
even more iconic things originated in
this series what about the Jedi the
Death Star Darth Vader well about our
good buddy Darth you remember Valerians
enlightens nope so I literally mentioned
them like 30 seconds ago if you can't
remember them either need to be paying
more attention or should probably get
checked out for anterograde amnesia Dori
is also in that waiting room anyway in
valerian enlightens where massive
helmets that cover their whole face just
like Darth Vader but you're probably
thinking that the enlightened outfit
looks pretty darn different from dear
old Darth right and they do they do look
different the enlightens are very
reminiscent of samurai right with the
horns and the mask you're probably
thinking to yourself darth vader looks a
little like them if you squint real hard
but not nearly so japanese well that's
only because you're seeing his final
design his original concept from George
Lucas was specifically a malevolent
figure in a cape with samurai armor the
final design of Vader reflects the full
face mask of the enlightened combined
with the base shape of a samurai helmet
but here's the clincher for this one in
Return of the Jedi when Luke removes
Vader's mask he reveals Vader's face a
face that's all burned and disfigured
but wouldn't you know it but in the
velaryon comics we also see under the
masks of the enlightened in empire of a
thousand planets and what we see is this
a burnt and disfigured face enemy
designs inspired by ancient Japanese
aesthetics with helmets covering
disfigured faces again I'll leave it up
to you to decide what's going on here
but even the biggest Star Wars
supporters out there can clearly see
that there are some strong similarities
between valerian and Star Wars and the
ones I pointed out don't even include
more general examples like the fact that
both Star Wars Episode two and valerian
have a clone army or that the Millennium
Falcon is the same nice flat disc shape
as valerian ship the intruder the
coloring the shape the texture even the
rear booster and ability to jump into
hyperspace so then what is our
conclusion
here to say that star wars outright
ripped off valerian ignores all the
innovative things unique to Star Wars
The Force lightsabers Death Star wookie
is a walks Yoda and on and on and on
sure the parallels don't make Star Wars
look all that great but it's not as
though it copied valerian word-for-word
concept for concept it borrowed elements
from other sources to remember when Luke
returns home and a new hope to find his
aunt and uncle's farm has been torched
yeah well Lucas has gone on record to
say that that was inspired by a John
Wayne movie called The Searchers from
1956 the attack on the Death Star at the
end of a new hope is even less
ambiguously borrowed from a 1955 British
World War two film called the dam
Busters instead of an x-wing squadron
going into a trench to fire on the Death
Star's single weak spot that dam Busters
has a squadron of fighter pilots flying
low against a riverbed to fire on a
single weak spot of the dam and while
that may not sound too similar on paper
if there's any question about whether
one influenced the other a side by side
comparison shows that Lucas basically
recreates the entire sequence
shot-for-shot and I mean it look at this
look at this I mean I'm trying to be as
neutral as possible here and I know the
valerian people want me to stay as
neutral as possible but come on
it is literally shot-for-shot angle for
angles seen by there even some who claim
that Star Wars overall plot is ripped
off of a samurai movie by Akira Kurosawa
called the hidden fortress one of the
most important people who claim that is
George Lucas himself in the documentary
the making of Star Wars when he says
quote hidden fortress was an influence
on Star Wars right from the beginning I
was searching around for a story I had
some scenes but I couldn't think of a
basic plot and then I thought of hidden
fortress which I'd seen in 1972 or 73
and so the first plots were very much
like it end quote
now I understand that some of this
evidence can be interpreted in multiple
ways but when the founder of the
franchise says he's trying to come up
with a plot
remembers in all
movie he saw and then models the initial
plot on that it's kind of hard to deny
but a real talk here today guys I know
that I gave Star Wars a really hard time
in today's episode i am a long-term
lover of Star Wars and I'm a new fan of
valerian both of these franchises are
great and to say that there was only one
original would be pretty unfair
sure Star Wars may have borrowed from
valerian but valerian borrowed from dune
and the samurai even Buck Rogers the
plots for valerian are really cool but
they're also the plots of stories like
Doctor Who which are also considered to
be groundbreaking and original the
cynical among us might just say that
this shows that there's nothing new and
everything in sci-fi is ripping off
someone else but I prefer a more
optimistic view an optimistic view
presented by one of the creators of
valerian and Laura lein himself beer
Kristine when he saw Star Wars in 1977
and recognized you know a lot of the
elements in it he didn't sue anybody or
even get mad according to an interview
in 2015 he said quote I was thrilled I
instantly felt connected with Star Wars
because of the number of intersections
and parallels with our comic strips and
you know what that's a pretty cool way
of approaching it because pretty much
everything is a retelling of something
and whether it's the Lion King retelling
Kimba the White Lion which is retelling
Hamlet or the matrix being a futuristic
retelling of the Bible or as Kristen
puts it in the same interview that's how
it goes in sci-fi it's all about copying
from one another or in other terms you
borrow something from someone else and
develop it further
Star Wars may have carried a torch from
valerian but that just means that there
are now two sci-fi franchises that we
can all enjoy but hey that's just a
theory a film theory and cut tis the
season of the forceful ah la la la la la
la la or star was theories coming of
course fallen la la la la la la la he'd
subscribe to see them all for la la la
la
ah ah coming out throughout the fall oh
no no no no no no no and damn funny see
on screen to check out the economic
ramifications and blowing up the Death
Star the Empire may not be as bad as you
once thought next week it's Rick and
Morty time so prepare to get swifty